hello everyone
thank you for joining in
and i hope everyone is in good health
and are doing good
so today we have gathered for the
session of cyanics it's a student club
for bioinformatics
subrajit bhairava my colleague is the
president of ceramics club and i myself
retrieve serving as the vice president
of the cyanide student club
our community comprises of more than
thousand plus students 20 plus
researchers and many more mentors and
peer reviewers who are a part of our
cyanic student club community together
we meet for sessions discuss and
brainstorm ideas and take the concepts
of bioinformatics at the next level in
order to discuss its application in
various other fields
what do we do and the topics that we
focus on are some of them are infectious
diseases microbiomes and microbes
precision oncology plant science and
neuroscience one of the main goals of
cyanic student club is to help students
and other people clear the concepts of
bioinformatics not only this but we also
help the students to gain insight on how
to use different tools of bioinformatics
and not only different tools but three
different tools
we also have pipelines and we
have like a hands-on workshop and help
them to learn how to apply the research
using bioinformatics in day-to-day life
we also help some students who are
interested in the coding part of
bioinformatics to learn the application
of coding in bioinformatics however
these data science skills together
help the students to apply the
bioinformatics knowledge in different
areas stated over here such as
neuroscience cancer microbiology and
infectious disease and many more
talking about what omics logic is so
omics logic platform is a platform whose
main goal is to provide training in
bioinformatics in order to enable
independent research which is guided by
mentors and peer example who have more
than a great years of experience in
academia industry and research
we are developing a growing community
with shared passion for data-driven
research and appreciation of citizen
science
we help students and clinicians along
with faculty of all backgrounds to
develop novel and independent research
projects using technology in life and
data sciences
speaking about one of our greatest
upcoming events is the omics logic
research symposium 2022 it is from march
31st and april 1st 2022
the main goal of the symposium is to
bring the peers the students the
mentors and the faculties researchers
and academicians together to form a
platform and interact about ideas and
ongoing research related to
bioinformatics education computational
sciences and further on
i myself was a part of this omics
research symposium last year where i had
a poster presentation and i won the
citizen project prize for the same
so this year also you guys can
participate in the poster presentation
competition whose details would be
shared in the chat box you can click on
the link and submit your abstract and
the further details would be shared in
the upcoming slides
as an experience and talking about the
experience i had for the poster
presentation was immense i got exposure
to so many new people i haven't met my
project got reviews from one of the best
universities in the world there were
speakers from georgetown university blue
marble space academy and they go they
gave me reviews on my project which
helped me improve further and showed me
directions about how to you know improve
and work on your project and in which
direction to work with overall it was
very helpful learning and improving uh
experience not only about this but you
also make connections which help you do
you know form deeper connections or find
your pathways or
in what field you should go to and
advisory kinds of connections
so the symposium topics for 2020
research symposium is new advances in
enabling technologies career
opportunities and the poster competition
that are talked about
we have academic experts from georgetown
university topper bioinformatics
research center google faba academy aims
research center blue marble space and we
have experts from our network partners
such as lbrn h3 bionet
and further on
talking about the topics that would be
covered in omics research symposium and
our confirmed speakers includes google
so they would be talking about google
cloud resources and the nih strides
initiative we have speakers from emitter
university which would be talking about
bioinformatics education and research
training at mit university noida
we have speakers from blue marble space
which is one of the renowned institute
for astrobiology and they would be
talking about carriers and internship
opportunities in astrobiology we have
another speaker from google which will
be talking about google's partner
programs and resources
similarly there are further more
confirmed speakers and if you want to
get involved in this kind of omics
research symposium then uh as a student
i am saying from my side that one one
should not miss this because it's one in
a lifetime experience and we did not do
not get listening to such speakers on a
daily basis so for the poster
presentation competition there were
these three posters that won the first
prize second prize and the best citizen
signs project price in the last year
you get amazing prizes and the exposure
to the peer reviewers and the industry
experts which is something we do not
usually get in all the conferences
the conferences poster presentation
themes for this year are omics and
bioinformatics artificial intelligence
machine learning and data science
astrobiology and space omics and
computational biology in biotech and
pharma
we have prizes for best poster
presentation best citizen science
project and young children have watched
this year
so starting with today's session today's
session would be conducted by dr mohit
mazumdar who is the business development
director and project mentor at pine
biotech today he will be speaking about
structural biology and research project
designing
so hello mohit sir the stage is all
yours thank you
hello everyone hi ruthvi thank you for
this wonderful introduction
and uh i hope that many of you will talk
about the session or talk about this
initiative called diamox and
help others to join as well in the
future
so today
we
planned uh to discuss
that
we will discuss about structure biology
and uh research project designing so one
of the
reasons for that is obviously the
upcoming symposium because it is an
opportunity where you can uh showcase
your poster presentation or or
presentation
so in that sense it helps
to incorporate good images and good
analysis
using uh maybe if you are interested in
structural analysis and i guess many of
you are that's why you are joining this
session or joining
for the session to learn so i hope that
many of you would do that
so a very good morning and very good
evening to all of you
wherever you all are
um so today
we will
be covering few important aspects
of structural biology analysis or you
know project designing
so
let me share my screen
just a second please so yeah so as i was
saying that um
uh i wanted to ask all of you before we
start actually that um how many of you
have like prior experience in structural
biology or using computational
structural biology
or like how does this interest comes in
so what is uh what is that you want to
do in structure biology so you can write
some of this in the chat i'll be happy
to know and learn about your interest
and then we can discuss some of those
things as well
so please feel free to write in the chat
and
we will have maybe um
discussion towards the end of this
presentation
so
all right
uh
yes uh so today in today's session
what we are going to do is that uh we
are going to over have an overview of
the very basics of structural biology
so i also that's why i also wanted to
know that
who have this experience in structural
biology so that i would know that how
much depth i have to go and if you're a
beginner in structural biology please
let me know in the chat that i'm a
beginner and i would want to go from the
very basic so
i mean from structured biology i want to
discuss about also the
current application of structural
biology and how it is uh it could be you
know applied in the context of a
research project so
that would involve you know
understanding how uh this field has
evolved what uh what different things
that have we have learned so far and
what is in application so what is that
is
used right now in in the industry in the
research labs and then also like from
the public data how do we you know
think about doing research projects or
research that that is possible uh so
through these different tools that that
we are going to review or like talk
about so in today's session and we are
going to start with an overview
very basic overview then we are going to
discuss a research project case study so
that would that case study would have
several aspects of research project
designing so that's how we are going to
cover uh some aspect of that through the
case study case study and then we will
also go into some
understanding of how like from sequence
to
uh to structure to function uh we will
try to understand all of that
uh in the context of the case study and
also like what is the downstream
analysis after that so um
and then we are going to look at some of
the um some of the new advancements so
we are going to look at uh some of the
things that have happened in in the
recent uh few months uh in the last few
months and uh what insights and that we
can gain from such studies and uh how do
we like you know design our own um
research based on some of the
information or some of the practice that
people in these publications uh have
done so we are going to review a few
publications and then we are going to
discuss about little bit about you know
how do we do the setup how to set up our
computational um
structural biology experiment such as
you know uh docking
and then we are going to discuss about
some of the
other methods
and after that we are going to talk
about the upcoming events uh one of
which is the symposium
which uh which we are very excited about
and we are hoping that many of you would
participate in there and also uh submit
your abstract and
and post us to compete so yeah that's
how
that's the plan and now let me look at
the chats
um just have to
beginner so there are a lot of beginners
here that's very good to know and um
[Music]
also please feel free to write like what
degree you are in so that i'll
understand that uh
what kind of things that we can do
together so this is also an opportunity
so to us then we are also going to
discuss opportunities and especially for
those who are like a little bit uh
proficient with this or would want to
become proficient with this and then we
will also have like opportunities such
as to work on project and also like um
internships and all so i hope that the
session would be helpful for all of you
and i look forward to have a more like
of interaction towards throughout this
session
so please feel free
to keep on writing in here in the chat
so that uh we can also discuss
uh the things that you are not getting
to understand or the the questions that
you have so now uh if you are a beginner
then
let's start from the basics and let's
answer a few questions
so uh
structural biology
um
how do you define structural biology so
structural biology um
sorry i'll have to just
stop my video
because of
the resolution
so because there's a lot of images uh so
yeah so structural biology is the study
of how a biological molecules are built
so we are looking at structures
so it's in three dimension uh so
i think many of you are also
you many of you are also fascinated to
understand that how uh a three
three-dimensional structures can be
analyzed or could be you know
understood and also uh in the context of
you know how fascinating it is from
two-dimensional or from sequence to
structure and from the structure to so
many different you know functions uh and
multimedialization and complex formation
is really a fascinating way that these
molecules work together so also the key
basis of our our existence so uh as i
was saying that uh that using variety of
you know imaging techniques uh
scientists view molecules in three
dimensions to see how they are assembled
how they are assembled how they function
how they interact all of those things
so that has helped actually researchers
understand how the thousands of
different molecules in each of this each
of our cells work together to keep us
healthy
so um this is one aspect like that
structural studies
because of the structural studies uh we
that has shown that how miss happens
molecules also like makes us sick and as
a result of these studies
uh um we have prompted new treatments in
many diseases so i'm talking about um
not only you know
understanding the way how things work
but also
understanding when things do not
work properly so understanding the
mechanism here so today we are going to
dive into some of the mechanistic
studies and i think that is important in
structural biology not just
understanding the tool but also the
science behind it the research behind it
so we will be this is kind of a research
oriented session
and i hope that many of you would
appreciate or and try to understand that
how to think about it and how to
conceptualize to come up with you know
ideas or do contribute in some of these
things through analysis and uh
yeah reporting and uh
imaging and all of that so
the first question that you that you can
see on the screen
is um
what are molecules so what are molecules
well molecules are group of two or more
atoms held together by a chemical bond
right
so molecules include dna rna proteins
and then carbohydrates sugars
lipids
which is fats so uh structural
biologists especially are particularly
interested in proteins
because uh they do so much of work i
mean they do so much of work in our body
so that is one of the reasons that we
many structural biologists
ah and there are so many structures of
proteins that you will find
so increasingly i mean biologists are
investigating large molecules that are
made up of uh combination of rna and
protein uh that are called rna protein
complexes uh but yeah
uh so what are proteins the next
question
and uh
if you know the answer to some of these
questions please feel free to write it
in the chat
and that would be great and
so yeah so proteins uh what are proteins
so proteins are molecules that
contribute to virtually every activity
in our body so uh they are they are
involved in
everything so they form hairs and
fingernails carry oxygen in our in the
blood allow muscles to move and like and
this can this will be an endless
list
so
next question uh what are proteins made
of
so proteins are made of long strands of
small molecules called amino acids
so amino acids
what are amino acids yes amino acids are
those small molecules with a certain
characteristics because of their
chemical
formulation so there are 20 amino acids
found in nature in uh each protein
contain contains a unique combination
of a few dozens of few dozens to many
thousands of these amino acids and today
we are going to review some of these uh
proteins formed of uh you know uh some
of the stretch of amino acids and fold
in a specific way so some protein
consists of multiple amino acid strands
wound together
so um that's about that
and now like uh the next question a very
important question is that uh
how does a protein gets its shape
so we are discussing today structural
biology of micro molecules and uh
proteins and
even though proteins are a string of
amino acids they do not remain as a
straight line as you know uh the strands
twists bends and folds into specific
shapes the way they fold um
uh depends in the uh depends on the part
of the way the minor is it interacts
with each other so in our case study
today we are going to see that how that
interaction
impacts the structure and how there are
if you replace some of those uh you know
amino acids that is like protein
designing how that impacts the structure
then and how can you predict that so
that's our case study today uh so yeah
so uh as i was telling you that uh some
of these proteins are they form standard
motifs so motives are like uh uh cox
crew like coils or called alpha highly
cells and flat sections are called beta
sheets so these are like uh motives are
uh defined based on their conservation
so
researchers can easily determine the
proteins amino acid sequence nowadays so
the trick has been to uh figure out how
and why protein fold so scientists are
beginning to solve that
puzzle with research into how amino acid
interacts and
they are using new computer programs uh
that can help predict protein motives
and many of you are aware of alpha fold
and we did cover it in the last session
also that how alpha works and
and
how it has has changed the
revolutionized the uh protein folding
problem
however i mean there is still a lot that
is required so we don't know the
structures of all the proteins and many
of our noble proteins and we don't know
how they fold so obviously all of this
information has been you know
possible through experiments
and those wet lab experiments include
some of those techniques that i'm going
to talk about in the next slide so uh
the next question then what does a
why does a protein shape matter
right
so um
a protein structure allows
it to perform a specific job look it's
it's to do a specific job that's why it
has a specific shape
so for instance antibodies are shaped
like a y
that helps these
that this helps these immune system
proteins to bind to a foreign molecule
such as bacteria or viruses with one end
while recruiting other immune immune
system proteins with others so the
design is made in a way that
it does it work uh it does its work
so
dna polymerase that you can see on the
screen
dna polymerase 3 is a donut shaped this
helps it to form a
ring around the dna as it copies its
genetic information and the proteins
called enzymes have grooves and pockets
that help them to hold on to other
molecule to speed chemical reactions
so similarly misfolding or mishappening
causes diseases and proteins
causes diseases they often stop working
properly and often can build up in
tissues so alzheimer's diseases
parkinson's diseases cystic fibrosis are
some of the examples caused by misfolded
proteins
so i hope that this
this basic introduction is helpful for
many of you and i know many of you are
already aware of this
so the next uh thing that i wanted to
discuss
is
what kind of proteins are out there
and how do scientists use protein
structure to develop new drugs
what are the examples of medicine
developed using structure based drug
design so because we are talking about
structure one of the main utility of
understanding the structure is also to
develop or design strategies to uh
overcome some of these challenges
related to diseases and all of that so
structure helps in that
because it gives you precise information
of uh of that molecule
and then uh obviously you can manipulate
and uh
design
based on uh based on structure so right
so um yes and then um like very basics
of how how do you determine structures
what are the different ways you can
determine the structure
um one of the latest technology what is
a cryo-em how does that work
so we are going to discuss all of that
in the slide so let's start with the
fact that um
that there are many proteins and there
are many different kind of proteins for
example many proteins are enzymes that
bind
that aid in biochemical reaction others
have shapes or functions that can help
cell
cells hold their shape and move as
described in the previous example
so another type of protein is are like
transporter proteins they are embedded
in the cell's outer membrane and form
channels that help vital substances such
as sodium or potassium to pass
sodium potassium calcium to pass in on
out of cell
so
there are different proteins which have
different functions and different uh
there are
involved in different pathways so
how do scientists use protein structure
to neutral earth so obviously drugs
typically work by either blocking or
supporting the activity of a specific
protein in the body right so using an
approach called structure based drug
designing scientists can make a template
of a protein and use that blueprint for
creating new medicines so they start
with a computerized model of protein
structure
and then they study it further so this
computerized model of protein structure
actually comes from an experimental
study so how that happens and what are
the algorithms involved from you know to
from uh
from uh
from a crystal structure to a
three-dimensional structure
is something that many of you might know
so so
but for example the computer model uh
allows uh researchers to examine how two
protein could work and if scientists
want to turn off one protein they can
design and alter a molecule that can
block or or alter that interaction so
these are some of the ways uh scientists
uh
do
uh a drug uh design new drugs so uh for
example like what is what would be an
example of medicine developed using
structure
based drug design
so yeah so
[Music]
i think researchers you know researchers
used structure basis drug designing to
drug design to develop some anti-hiv
drugs such iv protease i think is an
enzyme that keeps the virus alive
knowing it is its structure um allowed
researchers to determine the kind of
molecules that could stop hiv proteases
from working so scientists use computer
models to fine-tune these molecules that
could halt virus production so this work
led to a medicine called protease
inhibitors
which is available so how do scientists
determine protein structures now again a
very basic question
so
scientists researchers used several
imaging techniques to determine the
structure of proteins and other complex
molecules so cryo electron microscopy
cryo-em allows uh scientists to see
individual proteins as well as large
structures such as molecular complexes
groups of protein that combines and
function as a unit viruses or organelles
so bigger bigger structures can be
visualized with iom
x-ray crystallography and nmr so nuclear
magnetic resonance spectroscopy also
make it possible for researchers to do
view proteins and we will see one of
such case study today so today to date
researchers have used these techniques
to unravel the structure of more than um
1 lakh
22 000 some structures for some proteins
and they are available on the protein
data bank
uh where
you can
you can access them download them and
visualize them and understand them
better
so um okay
now the next question that i put
together for you
as you're not asking yourself so i'll
also look at the chat just for a second
all right
so uh
uh we were talking about cryo-em and
extracurricular cyclography and nnmr so
in cryo-em researchers rapidly freeze a
cell virus molecular complex or other
structures so that the water molecules
do not have time to form crystals
so this uh preserves the sample in a
natural state and then scientists you
use an electron microscope to blast the
frozen sample with an electron beam and
this creates a two-dimensional
projection of the sample on a digital
detector and by creating a hundreds of
projections of the sample from different
angles and taking the average of those
angles scientists generate a
three-dimensional model of the structure
so recent advancements in cryovm did
provide a highly detailed image of
proteins and other biological structures
including large structures such as rna
protein complexes
uh so another technique is actually
crystallography so extract
crystallography how does that work so
extract crystallography shoots a beam of
x-rays through a tiny solid crystal made
up of trillions of identical protein
molecules so one crystal has like a
lot many of protein molecules and that
crystal uh is placed in a way where
there is a
a beam hits it and the crystal scatters
the x-ray onto an electronic detector
similar to the way images are captured
in a digital camera
so
uh a computer then causes the intensity
of scattered x-ray to assign a position
to each atom in the crystallized
molecule so this results in a
three-dimensional digital image so this
method has been used to determine like
85 percent of
all known protein structures and very
very um
important uh
technique
so another technique i wanted to tell
you all about is nmr spectroscopy so nmx
spectroscopy works using natural magnets
the nuclei of certain atoms including
proteins so these natural cellular
magnets interact with a big magnet
inside the nmr machine the big the big
magnet forces the protein magnets to
line up researchers then blast the
sample into a series of split seconds
radio wave pulses and observe how the
sprue how the protein proteins magnetic
response so scientists use several set
of these nmr blasts and combine the data
to get a more complex picture of the
protein so although extra
crystallography can examine larger
proteins than nmr is able to do nmr has
those limitations that destruct the
sequence like is like usually
100 to
250 amino acid long uh i mean less than
100 is also fine but like uh that is the
range that usually nmr works really well
so nmr technology can be study can use
to study protein immersed in liquid
solution in contrast to x-ray
crystallography where you need to
crystallize the proteins and that is one
of one of the challenges that is there
to you know for crystallographer to
crystallize protein because it requires
an intensive process of screening and
trying different screens and then it's
very different it's very difficult uh
to get crystals and usually it takes you
to do phds and you know work on long
projects to come to get from you know
cloning and purification to
crystallization
and many of you who have gone through
that process could i agree more could
not agree more right so right
now um i mean how scientists view uh how
proteins act
uh that's an important question so uh i
mean new technology is beginning to
allow researchers to progress from
creating static
pictures of um you know from static
pictures of proteins to now making like
you know movies three-dimensional
structure and three-dimensional movies
uh
of with with their actions so images
provide snapshots of what these cellular
events are doing at a specific point of
time so if i'm talking about crystal
structure and even if i'm talking about
any of these structures so it's like a
picture right it's like a photograph
that you have clicked it's not a video
so in a video you see how a person is
moving you see all about other features
that you you do not understand in a
single snapshot
so
uh that's where i mean other techniques
comes then so
whether with a known structure so if i
know how a person
how tall is a person and if i can model
that person
and if i have a three-dimensional model
of that person and if i know the laws of
physics how a person moves so maybe i
can try to you know model the movement
that how it could be moving in a in a in
a
specific kind of an environment so i can
mimic that environment and that's how we
do molecular dynamic simulations
so as i was telling you that um
right so um
applying these and getting this
information uh and understanding this
dynamic system is critical to unlock how
life works because it is always dynamic
we are always moving so it's always
something happening so in addition there
is a whole class of proteins which which
are called intrinsically disorder
proteins they do not hold a specific
shape so many proteins
they do not
hold a specific shape they stay
disordered their shape is actually their
shape adapts to what's going on inside
the cell so there are signals making it
nearly impossible
uh i mean there are signals when they
they they're a part of their part of you
know uh
um
domain in in that protein uh get
structured so and that is based on
certain signal and it is really
difficult to capture those and get them
crystallized or get them to view them or
to picture them
so scientists are now using powerful
computer models to make molecular movies
so that they can see the full range of
proteins in live action uh by feeding
this information from various imaging
systems about how amino acid interacts
how building body building blocks
interacts sign now it's possible so that
is one of the things that i have been
also doing is to
be able to do simulations and to learn
about some of these interactions to
validate some of these interactions
which is kind of the last step
so um again like what is the future of
structural biology so we will end this
kind of uh overviews overview uh section
by talking about the future so
researchers on the frontiers of
structural biology and merging all kind
of imaging techniques so it's a
convergence of you know pictures extra
crystalography nmr cryo-em
this allows them i mean this allows all
of us to create a more precise map of
what proteins and other molecules look
like how they interact because the
interaction
the way the different molecules are
interacting uh we are getting more
evidences from these scientific
literatures studies and from connecting
those and connecting them through
structure scientists can create a single
image that zooms in to see the specific
proteins and zooms out to see how they
interact within the largest cellular
structure right
so
in addition to combining existing
techniques scientists are also
developing
more powerful techniques for example new
x-ray lasers
allow insights into the processes that
occurs in less than one tenth of a
trillion of a second much faster time
scales uh time scale that captures by
other sources of x-rays so through x-ray
lasers like very those are very
spontaneous processes can be also
captured scientists use super efficient
methods now to determine protein
structures more efficiently i told you
about alpha fold
[Music]
application of deep learning so deep
learning has contributed to major
advancements in predicting protein
structure from sequences a fundamental
that is like a fundamental
problem in structural bioinformatics so
with predictions now approaching the
accuracy of crystallographic resolution
in many cases and also not to not to
let this not mention let me also mention
this that this has been also possible
due to gpus and tpus so these gpus are
you know nvidia graphical processing
units units that transform this
ability for computers to do so much high
end computing
and it's kind of affordable for labs
also so i mean that helped in fast
genome level structure prediction so not
only just predicting one structure but
predicting this entire uh you know
proteome of uh uh
individual so that sort of scaling is
required and that has been come through
the technological advancement and is
getting to uh it's coming up so um i
mean
this is this is possible through
state of our art deep learning models
and obviously wealth of uh new data for
system biology applications
so yeah i mean that's how we conclude
this
right
i think uh your slides are not changing
due to some
reason okay i will stop sharing and then
i will share again so yeah i was
concluding this part of this
this part of
the session
where we discuss about the overview and
it is meant for all beginners
to learn about some of these aspects
going into the next part of the session
so next part of the session is kind of
special because it's uh
my phd thesis work
and that's the case study also
so
um okay so we don't have a lot of time
so let me quickly do that
yeah there is some issue
with
sharing
okay so um next part of the presentation
which we will be discussing is a case
study so from sequence to structure to
function to prediction to design
so uh some of the objectives that we are
going to cover is how uh designing a
workflow to predict calcium binding
sites in uh ef hand proteins um
and understanding what protein family is
how hummer is used 3d structures
then the second part of this objective
second part of the present
about this
case study is predicting the calcium
binding affinity to facilitate protein
engineering um which is to do which is
to do data mining hypothesis testing and
machine learning so this is all in the
respect of structural biology
and uh how this is playing now how from
sequence to structure to function uh uh
this is a case study so uh briefly to
tell you that what the objectives are is
to
predict this site that you see on the
screen
so on the left side you see that there
is a
hand that shows uh with two thumbs uh
which donates uh denotes two helices and
in between there's a loop
where you can see a ca which stands for
calcium so calcium is found to be
uh
seen to be binding in this ef and uh
motif and this especially into this
groove where you will see that that it
forms a
specific kind of uh geometry so that
geometry is maintained through
binding to the
residues at 1 3 5 7 and 12th position
so these are important positions in the
respect of respect of the
respect of this study
that we are going to discuss
so in this case of full residue
canonical ef and and this is
this could be seen in molecules such as
calm modulate and i don't know many of
you have heard of this molecule is a
pretty important molecule uh which binds
calcium primarily via side chain
carboxylates so the loop sequences as i
was telling you 1 3 and 5 12 are the
positions from where
they it gets to those oxygen molecules
uh from the carboxylate and then it
composes of a highly conserved like this
uh loop so this loop is something that
we have to predict from the protein
family so this is the uh
the in below um you will see that there
is a list there is a
graph
that has residues written into it so it
don't it it signifies the
um
frequency of these amino acids found in
the entire family so
an entire family is like sequences from
different organisms
across and uh
and then that is where
you can find those families in pe fam is
one of the famous a popular website
where you will
you can download those families and you
can use
hammer tools to see if you uh to see and
find that if those your sequence has
those proteins uh or those protein
families present or not so if you're
scanning genome wide or like that
meaning you many you many users use that
technique to scan for protein families
so in this example i mean you will see
that there is a specific pattern that
i'm talking here about so this big d
that you see
is it the is at the first position and
uh it it goes till the
word e
before the f and l so it's a 12
mer stretch these 12 residues are
responsible for binding to calcium and
they play important role uh in holding
the calcium ion there and uh based on
their strength you can determine if the
calcium is binding going to bind if then
a high affinity or a low affinity so
there is some correlation between the
sequence and the binding affinity of
calcium with the sequence uh that is
something that we want to predict so
here the third objective is to predict
calcium binding affinity and the
hypothesis here is that the sequence has
to play a role with the binding affinity
and if we change and vary the sequence
the binding affinity is also going to
vary so i mean in what context are we
talking are we saying that
if the sequence is more conserved if
these preferred residues at this
positions are
are more are available then it will have
a higher binding affinity so that's the
hypothesis that we started with
now uh the the next step is to develop
flow chart or develop algorithm to uh to
find this to do this like one after
another so pipeline
so
we developed two pipelines uh one
pipeline is to predict the
that 12 more so this is 12 ma that you
can see from d to e and you can see that
there is a good pattern here so if my
machine learning algorithm
where i am going to train these
sequences that are already known to bind
calcium by to bind calcium
if i can
model this and tell this
model machine learning model that look
these are the places these are the
sequences that are highly conserved and
please look for these sequences and let
me know if you find some
so that's the first model
and uh to do that i mean you you this is
the workflow so first
from the big chunk big sequences so the
input the user i mean if someone wants
to find
ef and dual mus binding site how do how
how to facilitate that a person who is
going to look for a specific stretch is
going to submit from
a big sequence so a sequence could be a
protein sequence a sequence could be a
whole genome or whole proteome uh so
yeah that is your input so input has big
sequences so that big sequences is now
broken down into 12 to 12 12 months
in a scanning way so that you i mean so
that the algorithm can get there
can find uh can work uh and predict from
the 12
that it is that is being generated
through the first steps but the first
step is to to break it into 12 more
sequences which is the size of the
active site now the next step is to you
know convert that alphabetics
order that is there present into um
into machine learning input which is
numbers which are numbers so uh
we developed uh
which we used uh the the pattern based
recognition which is like binary
so
in binary what you do is that you assign
uh these 20 amino acids with their own
unique
patterns so for example if you if if it
is 1 zero zero like 20 20
numbers are there and you keep on
changing the
position of one
for 23 positions then you have a pattern
for binary similarly amino acid
composition is one of the feature so
these are some of the features that are
taken uh to develop it into a net
machine learning model now after the
machine learning model is is developed
and tested and
validated on
on different data sets you figure out
that how it is working
how is it being able to predict the
sequences or the binding sites correctly
or not how do you validate that you can
validate that by downloading all the
structures that are there in pdb that
binds to calcium and look at those um
those binding sites and then you can
test your algorithm to
by checking one of the sequences if it
is correctly predicting the
binding site or not so that is the first
hypothesis hypothesis second hypothesis
is that it what is the what is the
correlation between the sequence
and the function which is the binding
affinity so how do you predict the
binding affinity of a c
of a sequence and from the sequence and
relate it to some experimental value
so you need obviously
some correlation
so that is what i'm going to tell you
about the next slide in our next slide
so um
with the literature so next part is to
do literature review so when you are
conducting or in when you are kind of
starting an experiment or research for
first you need to
find where the data is
and then you do some exploratory
analysis and you see the pattern and
based on that pattern then you go to the
next level and start designing your
machine learning so here we did a lot of
combination permutation and that
involves amino acid features so we what
the input sequence is remember the input
sequence is amino acids so
amino acids have to be converted into
different type of you know uh based on
based on their different features so
amino acids have also different maybe
charge
all amino acids have different charge so
you can check you can differentiate
based on their charge and similarly you
can differentiate about
with their hydrophobicity and
all of those features so these are the
features that have been inserted
inputted into the machine learning that
based on these features you classify if
they are following a pattern or not so
um
two machine learning models were
designed and
created one is to predict the binding
um
binding site so your input is a protein
sequence and the binding sites are
predicted here you can see four binding
sites are predicted with this svm score
and the second part is to predict the
binding affinity so if if it is pre
predicted as by predicted the binding
site next you what you want to do is to
know how
strongly or how loosely it's going to
point to calcium all of this through
automation you just have to get a
sequence and you're getting all this
information through automation and you
through all these analysis and that's
the project
so uh the first paper uh showcased all
of this we published this uh and
published with a 100 accuracy for
prediction of the binding site because
you see there is a high level of this
pattern is very good so
the
the model was able to easily distinguish
between binders and non-binders uh
basically based on these features that
aspartate is being seen at the first
position a lot of times and if you
mutate this as but it
to alanine you will see that the binding
affinity is either lost completely or
it's very loose so this is an important
residue so these are the features that
model you know the machine learning
model uh model through and then what we
did like we have created this model and
got published and all of that the next
thing that we did was to design
um our calcium binding site which will
have a high binding affinity based on
this hypothesis so we looked into all
the binding sites again and looked into
their affinity
and uh all of that literature review was
done and then we found out uh then we
thought of designing uh
designing a protein which will bind
calcium very strongly based on our
hypothesis based on our algorithm so the
algorithm also gives an output score
with each each prediction so if the
score is high
the binding is high and if the score is
low the binding is low so based on that
and based on the uh based on the things
that are available uh in the lab
which is the anti-histolytica ehca bpp1
protein uh we were able to uh
do this experiment where we mutated uh
one of the protein and made it to bind
with high affinity with calcium so our
hypothesis that was that if we change
these positions that you see here
in the
d panel uh of
of the
left side of the image is that this is
the designed one d k d g d g f i d f e e
so d is as per it and like similarly
this aspect
is kept
as it is at surface position and then
alanine is changed into lysine and then
similarly
there are other mutations where
phenylalanine is added and also like
this what these were like not very
drastic mutations but those mutations
were something that were not done before
anyone did not thought of ever to think
about like how these these residues are
going to play a key role in this design
molecule so we further what we did was a
lot of structural analysis and that's
why i wanted to also uh show you like
what are the different ways you can do
this visualizations in your project so
these are the different ways you can
visualize so we found out that uh the
protein structure changed and there is a
uh there's a movement 7.1 degree
movement in the mutated protein when we
compared it to the native protein and we
like mutated it and then crystallized it
and then found out that there is a huge
uh change in there are slight changes in
the active site that made this entire
protein
do a lot of different things so from a
trimeric protein it became a
may become a hexametric protein and then
the overall like we did a lot of
analysis like mapping the active site so
calculating the distances from each of
these atoms and then plotting and
understanding that how these are being
changed from the native and the mutant
and then uh like understanding that how
these changes are there in the chains of
these molecules not only at a local
level but also at a global level so from
a local level how do you
see the changes in a global level so
these all are could be done through a
simple
uh
simply uh using some of the tools that
we are going to cover in our upcoming
program structural biology program but
yes i mean it's something that anyone
can do if uh with some guidance
obviously and understanding like how
things uh are you know
connected to
that is very understanding that is very
important to understand that how
local local events lead to a global
event event and how these how to map
these changes and you know give us solid
scientific evidence to the community
that this is how it works and tell the
everyone so this is what i'm talking
about in the next image the next image
is another an example of an analysis so
here what we are trying to do is to map
uh the
the sequences again to uh based on their
movement so this is a
dynamic movement is being captured
through vca and in this you will see
positive and negative correlation
so there's a comparison of three
structures here and in this comparison
what
networks are derived where residues that
are colored uh colored in us uh
clustered in the same group are colored
alike like the red ones so
by this you can unders you can try and
understand that how the dynamic cross
correlation between residues and the
entire structure has changed between a
one one um
one structure to another to another and
that sort of comparison when you're
doing comparison uh at a local level and
also seeing how the changes are affected
and what are the what are the residues
who are responsible for these changes
and how they are doing it because their
interaction map is changed as you can
see that the image changed from uh from
one from a to b to c and there are
slight changes that that you can observe
when you look closely in the map also so
these slide changes changes the
characteristics of the entire molecule
its function and this is something that
we wanted to map in the study using
machine learning and also these
techniques so i wanted to show in this
case study to you is that how different
types of analysis can give you different
kind of results
and you know
new discoveries in this area and which
is quite possible to do in you know many
other uh many other aspects so also like
coming back to this uh this another case
study so i think uh maybe we will be uh
we will be doing this in our next
session when we when we
meet again so i'll just not go in more
depth about the other case studies that
i put together but yeah i also wanted to
discuss with you some of these like
docking and all so i think we can
schedule another session soon but yes i
mean uh before we conclude today's
session i wanted to also tell you about
uh this program also some of these
events which are upcoming so that uh
when we get the opportunity then we
learn about all of this so from from in
march we have a lot of events coming up
and many of you are welcome to join
because many of the all the fun sessions
of these sessions will be free and also
uh many of them are completely free like
the homicide symposium and i would
request you also to share this with the
others who could benefit from
these upcoming events uh i and uh we'll
be happy to share the links also of the
symposium and also the workshops so it
is associated with the symposium so
there are guest lectures in these
workshops that you'll find and uh the
symposium will have a lot of great
speakers uh in in the next month in in
ma in may uh we have programs coming in
like working with r and working with
python space omega infectious diseases
and this is the program that i wanted to
tell you about that is going to start in
april 11th and may 11th is the
structural game information structure
biology and before i conclude i also
wanted to tell you that um
i'm looking for students who are
efficient and
are good in structural biology to work
on on certain aspects and some projects
and this is not a paid internship but
this is like an internship that you can
do with me and learn about many of these
uh projects how they have worked on and
how we can use this in different aspects
so thank you so much for inviting me for
today's session and i would like to pass
it back to root 3 to conclude the
session thank you so much
thank you so much sir for this
enlightening talk um
i would like to take some questions
there are pretty much questions in the
audience so i'll just speak out to you
so the first question is what are
algorithms used to predict ca binding
efficiency
so usually when the project started
there are there were
no such algorithms there were some
algorithms
which are not working efficiently so
this is one of the only from sequence
but yeah from structure if you know the
structure of the protein then you can
predict binding affinity through
molecular dynamic simulation calculation
free energy calculations and
some other methods which are
which requires can
quantum calculations quantum chemistry
calculations yes
okay so since we are running late
uh i would like everyone to bring in
their questions to mohitzer at his email
address that is muhit pine dot bio for
now i would like to introduce you to the
programs and which are already
introduced that are coming in the spring
semester so i would greatly recommend
you all to be a part of these programs
because they are very fun learning and
especially for beginners in
bioinformatics this is the platform for
you guys
so you can scan this qr code in order to
register for the omics research
symposium and the symposium is a free
event to attend for all students all at
all levels including faculty
professionals and experts and all
background
the deadline to submit your poster
abstracts is march 10 2022 you can
register yourself at the email in the
links provided in the chat box
and
we at pine bio have different platforms
on which we can connect with you that is
facebook instagram linkedin youtube and
twitter the links would be shortly
shared in the chat box
and it would be really great of you guys
to just scan and feed uh fill this
feedback form in order to help us you
know improve in the future sessions you
can even tell us what kind of sessions
you want in the future
and just to give you a